c'est le monument le plus visité de
france et même d'europe et c'est aussi
le passage quasi obligé de tous les
touristes qui viennent à paris la tour
eiffel car c'est d'elle qu'il s'agit
reçoit chaque année près de 6 millions
de visiteurs est aujourd'hui parmi les
trente mille touristes qui ont
courageusement grimper les escaliers ou
qui ont plus classiquement emprunter les
ascenseurs la tour eiffel a attendu son
sens 50 millionième visiteur le compte à
rebours a débuté dès ce matin et
philippe panis et patrick goupillon ont
attendu et même guetter ce visiteur
historique qui va être particulièrement
choyés dans cette queue au pied du
pilier nord le sens 50 millionième
visiteur de la tour eiffel s'ignorent
encore mais dans les coulisses le
décompte se poursuit' comme au premier
jour de l'ouverture de la tour au public
le 15 mai 1889
depuis l'origine de la tour des
registres ont été tenus journellement de
l'entrée des visiteurs dans la tour et
depuis très peu de temps c'est relayé
par un système informatique qui va nous
donner le top
le top c'est à 17h52 fanfare bousculades
et direction le quillier nord oublié de
se présenter de 50 millionième visiteur
des dizaines de journalistes de tous les
pays au coude à coude un événement avec
une chose qui est un symbole surtout
pour les étrangers ayant demandé
américaine notre préférence est séparée
c'est même la france
vous vouliez l'avoir la voici la
chanceuse du jour se cache derrière
d'élégantes lunettes noires elle est de
carcassonne mais travaille en région
parisienne
gardienne de la paix elle gagne une
voiture mais a provisoirement d'autres
préoccupations vous avez perdu votre
famille près de six millions de
visiteurs en 1992 la tour eiffel
monument payant le plus visité de france
devrait accueillir son 200 millionième
client dans 7 8 ans lui aussi sera
couvert de cadeaux mais rassurez-vous
ici il y a des souvenirs pour tout le
monde